so you're not going to answer the
question if you're running
but I'd love to but I can't I'm not
allowed to legally if I said it you know
it has a whole it's ridiculous what
would you do thinking through this you
gave me you surprised me one night with
an answer I asked you what would you do
differently and you said I'd stop
fighting with the media because they're
corrupt and a waste of my time did you
really mean that you would stop fighting
with the media well I think I fight with
him a lot less I mean I believe the term
fake news came or emanated I think it's
branded right across I think it was
tattooed into their foreheads I think
I've explained that yeah
um
if I didn't fight
my presidency would have been a failure
and the country would have been way way
down you have to without the fighting on
policy but what about the I'd love to be
able to get along with the media uh I
respect many people in the media you a
lot thank you when you see Pulitzer
prizes going to people that got Russia
Russia Russia totally wrong I got it
right it's very and you got it right and
John Solomon got it right and Sarah got
it right and Craig we could Greg Jared
incredible there are some people that
got it right that should be rewarded but
you can't reward the people that got it
wrong exactly the opposite so you
wouldn't you talk to them my question is
so what when you think back do you have
any regrets yeah do you wish why the
hell did I do that why didn't I do that
you ever think about that or so you
always have regrets
but my biggest regrets are people when I
went to Washington I was only there 17
times I've told you this and I never
stayed overnight so I wasn't into that
whole world of the Washington DC Society
I was from New York I spent I knew
everybody in New York now I know
everybody and I know the good ones the
bad ones the weak ones do you think you
would be better because your team and
the people around you would be better
and stronger I think so I know so but we
also are great people don't forget I
rebuilt our military we knocked out a
hundred percent of Isis we did things
that people don't even talk about
there's so many we did over a thousand
things right to try where you're able to
try drugs that won't be approved for
another five years if you're terminally
ill that was a big thing uh Israel I've
met people the Jews lives were saying
this look at Jerusalem the capital of
Israel Abraham affords
we did so much we did so much but
um
the big thing is people I I could have
had a couple of choices a few choices
maybe even more than a few choices that
I wouldn't have put a certain person
there you know government is largely
people now I know everybody I know the
good ones and I know the bad but today
was a day where your family was impacted
directly your children well I know all
of them really well and I've known them
for a lot of years anytime I went to
interview you before you ever thought
about really running for president you
always introduced me and all nice
they're all great kids all of them they
are great kids and I've met Baron who's
a great kid and
you know I've watched now you watch what
happened to them today and what they've
all had to go through and all the
depositions and all the legal
stuff that goes on do you worry about
putting other people what Melania had to
go through and baron had to go through
do you worry about putting them back in
that situation in other words I'm going
to say put it nicely you're a golfer
yeah why don't you just play God why why
would you want to give up a great life
and go back to that hellhole because I
love the country and we were so close
before covid came in we had a country
like never in history we were going up
and even with that I saw your friend
Laura the other night to a show on the
numbers of tremendous numbers with covet
you know and again when it came nobody
knew what it was it was China's gift to
us okay a horrible gift but even with
covet my numbers are better than
anybody's numbers in in decades you
could add Bush and Obama together forget
Biden because look his stock market now
is lower
then where mind was and you're talking
about two years later you think my stock
market hit a record even after covid
when I handed it off if you call it a
handoff my stock market was higher than
it was the day before covet came in I
mean we did an amazing job so final
question and thank you gave us a lot of
time thank you
so you think Biden would give you this
much time no I don't think you'd be
answering you want to know my honest
answer I don't even think he knows
today's Wednesday that's my honest
answer I say it right I hope he does for
the sake of this country I hope he does
it's very gracious I should tell a story
about one time you requested that I go
easier on him he did say that to me he
thought I was being a little too
flipping I think that it was too tough I
thought you were very tough
and I thought and I will say this
um forget politics and the Republican
and the Democrat stuff and the radical
left side of everything else
I want somebody that's a great leader I
want somebody that can stand toe-to-toe
with President XI of China you can go I
said this the other you could go all
over Hollywood and try and get somebody
to play the role of President XI the
president of China there is no actor
like that there's nobody like that these
are Fierce People he's a fierce man he
was I was a very good friend of his
until covert came in then I gave him up
I said this is too much you know I made
a great unbelievable trade deal with
China I made it unbelievable trade deal
getting rid of NAFTA the worst trade
deal ever made and replacing it with
usmca that now Mexico and Canada want to
renegotiate because the deal is so good
we did unbelievable things but we need
our sharpest people because people like
President XI like macron like I could
name so many of them like Putin but of
course right now he's having a different
kind of a spell but but let me tell you
these are Fierce People
they're smart they're tough they don't
know about losing Putin's having a hard
time and be very careful what's
happening he's being handled incorrectly
but these are very strong smart people
and Beyond Republican or Democrat I want
to see somebody that's great you want
Joe Biden to succeed
I would rather have him succeed
incredibly
even if it meant a much tougher and
maybe even a loss I want to see what's
good for the country if if I had my
choice of having this mess that we have
in there right now this country is a
mess
this country is not going to survive the
way it's going right now it's not going
to so you'd be willing to go through all
the hell that we talked about today and
all that you've been through all these
six years because you put your country
first this is is this a calling I put
the country first yeah I mean it's uh
I had I had you knew me long before I
ran for public I had one of the great
lives I had the greatest places in the
world I had the greatest everybody
should live your life the most
incredible you worked hard yeah you know
it's very funny we I was heading into a
a big event at the convention center
Robin Hood you know what Robin Hood is
tremendous numbers like four or five
thousand people
and half the people were cheering wildly
and half the people were booing I had
just announced that I was running my
wife looked at me
Melania she said do you know darling
nobody's ever been I've never heard
anybody booing you before I said welcome
to the world of politics right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else